let's break the ice and get to know I
know J okay this I see this Abascal
okay you see it so it's gonna get hot I
don't know I love this so much
I could drink this this is my first time
playing spin the bottle really yeah I
know it's been the butt of a point okay
so we're not getting too racy we're only
gonna do the truth okay okay you're not
gonna bring a boy in for like me I know
I'm not gonna I'm sorry actually like
there should be like these cards should
have a contestant
I'll ask me like who's coming up this
one is your first one so most
embarrassing moment while performing on
stage I had two things I forgot the
lyrics to a song one time so and it was
such an easy song I was like there's
like one of it because it fits records I
think it was worth it I was like just
give me this give me you and I forgot
and then I went I just told a crowd and
then it was a wardrobe malfunction oh
man I had I've had like lots of those
okay I only share one I was dancing too
hard that the zipper in my back bra
strap like ripped off and I had a race
offstage and I felt it and I ran to my
security who's like I look at as my
uncle and I'm like help me with this
it's a red bow there's no woman there
there's not there no women in back so he
was trying help me is like I don't know
so he tried his best and I came back out
it was fine but it was the scary I'm
glad that nothing you know popped out it
wasn't too obvious with you to love it I
felt it and my pack came off - yeah I
was pretty bad yeah okay let's see what
you get next let's spin this bottle this
one yeah I don't know okay so this one
says are you in love or have anyone
special in your life I have someone
someone in mind have friends your friend
okay so you're not looking for love
right now I'm a cancer that's my zodiac
sign cellular heavily and it's kind of
like a blessing in a curse oh I hear
that I love the idea of love
but I don't know sometimes I'm afraid to
commit sometimes just because I've
already gone through so much before yeah
that you expect more in the next and
you're like I don't know
are you husband material are you ready
are you ready for this I'm extra and I
read all these memes and I'm all them
focus on you bro give me that I love
that that was a good one thank you
that's the best one I was your best man
yeah saw that okay
your biggest splurge after fifth harmony
fame biggest blurred I got me a house a
house mhm
okay so is this like a house for
yourself or like family is invited over
do they live with you both okay
yeah and I'm working on my next one for
myself so why is he yeah I had 21 yeah
that's a man I could have done this
sooner but there is like some of the
people that I wanted to take care of
first before I don't know I hate being
that kind of person I could easily do
something for myself but just not in me
to do that I'd rather take care of
others okay let's do one more
ooh what are you most self-conscious
about um it used to be my body your body
I used to be my body but then I found I
had to finesse that with some very good
fitting clothes but I would just find
the right clothes to fit me perfectly
just cuz I can't like I have curves yes
I'm just like oh I can't wear things
that petite girls would work yeah won't
always look good on you so anytime I'm
shot being like online I had to be
cautious of that and make sure that as
I'm looking at these clothes that how
would it look on me how do my legs what
are my favorite qualities about
yourselves and myself and I love showing
my legs I like yeah great thanks thank
you I know how to finesse that too so
yeah you always got just yourself the
way you know your body yeah and you know
your body best and you know what makes
you feel confident in that girl I think
you look great thank you don't know why
you were ever self-conscious about that
you